hello everyone this is Mark Newton from
Stanford University and welcome to the
next session of the beach a guide to the
fundamentals of data science it's a real
pleasure to introduce a speaker for
today who is Michel de Monte a from
Stanford University Michel is an
associate professor of biomedical
informatics at Stanford before he would
before he was at Stanford he was at
Carleton University in Canada and has
had a long career in semantic technology
and is the co-chair of the w3c
healthcare life sciences interest group
where he said enormous impact on the
field and developing approaches to using
semantic technology in the biomedical
applications the idea event ontology
obviously is very old dates way back to
the Greek philosophers but in the past
20 to 30 years has had a enormous impact
on the field of big data and we shall
we'll be talking about that Michel
Hey thank you very much like for that
introduction and thank you also for the
organizers to give me the opportunity to
sort of share my thoughts on ontology
and I hope that throughout this
presentation if you have any questions
feel free to put them in the chat box
and we'll try to address them at the end
and so for today's talk I'm hoping to
tell you a little bit about what
ontology czar and why we should perhaps
be using them a little bit about
building and reasoning over oncology's
and then some applications in
biomedicine so what is an ontology well
ontology stands for logical discourse of
existence and the real goal of ontology
is to uncover and describe the nature
and structure of things spinning as Mark
said predominantly the domain of
philosophy is a very long history in the
field of metaphysics and it's been
associated with you know prominent
philosophers such as Plato and Aristotle
now in case of Plato he mostly focused
on what he called forms which they were
kind of conceptual they could be of any
kind of thing and not really are
necessarily tied to to reality whereas
Aristotle focused on an empirical kind
of analysis where the
types of things that we see are really
as a result of what we we exhibit what
actually exists but currently exists so
ontology the study of ontology attempts
to address questions such as what does
it mean to be what constitutes the
identity of an object and what
categories can we sort existing things
into and you know as as this this field
has developed I think the principle
ideas that ontology particularly when
they're communicated to others foster a
shared understanding of things the
nature of things and their structures
and relationships so early biologists do
include in Aristotle
you know fourth century BC three century
BC where he developed made many
contributions to the field of ontology
and also provided for systematic taxa
taxonomy of biology the classifications
of organisms were typically by some
shared properties and used this binomial
nomenclature that focus on genus
differentia and I'll talk a little bit
about that Gallen is another also very
famous individual that focused on the
medical applications and medical
ontology for the systematic description
of diseases science and symptoms and he
also used this first italian genus
differential approach so what is this
well this approach is really key I think
to building good ontology x' it's a kind
of intentional definition where you do
provide the necessary sufficient
conditions in the definition and you can
see that definitions are composed of two
parts the first is the genus which
serves as the basis for a new definition
and basically all definitions that
contain this genus component are
considered to be members of that genus
and then the other component is some
differentiate something that tells you a
little bit more specifically about what
differentiates this this type of thing
from any other type so for instance if
you have a say a type like a rhombus you
can define it as a quadrilateral so the
quadrilateral part is the genus and of
course that would be defined else
but you're using it as a basis to form
your own definition here and the
particulars of the rhombus is that has
bounding sides which all have the same
length and so we can build on that to
define a square we can say square is a
rhombus so it inherits the properties
that we've described above and it also
has interior angles which are all right
angles so in this way when we build
ontology x' we can in this way we can
sort of navigate it almost like a a
binary decision tree you can look at the
properties and see if it fits and
continue down that branch or perhaps go
down a different branch based on that
structure so for instance for
Aristotle's categories the main object
type was substance or one of the more
important ones was substance and then
you had a differential which would be
for instance whether the object was
material or immaterial it was immaterial
it was a kind of spirit if his material
is a kind of body and then you had two
other differentia where you look whether
they are the body was in adamant in
which case it would be a kind of mineral
and if it was adamant he would be living
and similarly for living you'd look is
it sensitive or insensitive and if it
was sensitive it was an animal and then
from an animal you look at whether it
was rational or irrational and that
would lead you eventually to the
category of human and then from which
individuals that exist the world would
instantiate this this category and would
basically if we would infer that humans
were rational sensitive adamant and
material substances biologists have a
long history of trying to do
classification and of course this
example is no better known than in
biological taxonomy where we have
different kinds of categories to
describe the different living organisms
that we see in the world today at the of
one of the three main kingdoms is
animals for instance and these are
divided into phylum into classes orders
families genus and species
this is while there are other different
kinds of ranks or the classification
these are the main ones and you can see
that at least in this diagram how it is
simply articulated the diferencia to go
from one from the parent categories into
more specific categories so for instance
for animals they are organisms that are
able to move on to own coordinates our
animals with a backbone mouths or
chordates with fur or hair and milk
plants and so on all the way up to Homo
sapiens
so this basically instantiates a kind of
taxonomy where we have a hierarchy of
inheritance where you have an is our
relationship that every instance of a
chordate is also an instance of an
animal and so on so we can really see
this kind of this structure this
taxonomic structure where you have an is
a relationship that holds between one
set of objects another set of objects
and so you can see on the right hand
side this kind of illustration that the
entities that are considered to be
mammals are also considered to be
chordates but coordinates are not only
don't only necessarily contain mammals
but could contain other kinds of species
and similar with animals adult chordates
or kinds of animals but then there could
also be other kinds of animals present
so moving from this more you know this
early understanding or development of
ontology there's been this increasing
trend to I guess in some sense
operationalize ontology to make it to
apply it to into computational context
and this has been as mark said an
evolution over the past you know 30 40
50 years where people have been thinking
a little bit more about what does it
mean to apply these kinds of categorical
systems to things and how do we use them
so Tom Gruber is also a very important
individual in this context
was one of the developers or inventors
of the Siri application which you can
use on the iPhone and he he put forward
that an ontology was an explicit
specification of a conceptualization so
let's break that down so
conceptualization is the way that we
think about the domain something that we
can articulate to others and the
specification is some way of writing
that down
borås 1097 sort of extended this to say
so let's focus on that and let's say a
formal specification and again formal in
the sense that you have a formal
language which you can use to describe
the specification in an unambiguous way
and you also specify that it should be a
shared conceptualization so it's not
sufficient that you just articulated
with a formal language but the
definitions and meanings that you have
are are shared amongst different groups
and then Gruber came back a little bit
later and again we have a much more calm
attic approach to the description of
ontology where he says the ontology
specifies the vocabulary with which to
make assertions which may be inputs and
outputs of knowledge agents for instance
a software program but ultimately then
an ontology must be formulated in some
representational language so this these
kinds of requirements are a little bit
different than what we might see for
other kinds of classification systems so
for instance in a folksonomy
which were very accustomed to when we're
tagging for instance images or making
annotations of some kind we use a some
collection of terms to enhance the
overall ability to navigate through
different kinds of content but it's not
necessarily really formally organized
it's mostly loosely coupled with our
intuition but what those terms mean and
in some cases you know people can can
use synonyms for exactly the same
concepts so there's not much constraint
here in contrast so a glossary really
provides both the terms and some
definition and potential explanations of
our examples of use control vocabulary
would focus more on some enumeration
of terms that are defined so that they
can specifically be shared and reused
and and so communities would adopt some
particular set of terms and sort of
ensure that these are well understood by
members of the community and use in a
coherent manner and then going back to
the hierarchies again or just a nested
set of terms but the relation between
one term and another can vary so for
instance in a proper taxonomy you would
expect to use this is our relationship
right so every every mammal is a kind of
animal but in a mirana me then you
really this relationship is a part of
relationship right so you have for
instance the arm would be part of the of
the body or something like that and
finally a classification in which
ontologies typically are is a set of
categories in which contracts are
grouped into what you can sort and for
instance data into or any other thing so
what do we want to develop an ontology
well primarily there are a few different
main use cases the first is to provide a
formal specification of biomedical
knowledge something that we can
represent in a way that is relatively
unambiguous that both people and agents
can understand and consume and use in
some way one of those ways is that they
can do this classification task by
looking at the definitions or looking at
the difference yet and trying to apply
them to for instance data we use them to
develop a common understanding of the
kinds of entities in a given domain and
the relationships that exist between
them and we use them to enable reuse of
data and knowledge in different contexts
and ultimately in our in in our case for
many of us in this community that are
listening to this webinar as we try to
use ontology to enable biomedical
discovery so one of the most famous and
well are well-known ontologies and
biomedical domain is the gene ontology
there are millions of annotations on
hundreds of thousands of genes that use
the gene ontology terms the gene
ontology
finds types of used to describe a
describe gene function and it basically
has three main categorical aspects the
first is molecular functions or do gene
products do the second is cellular
component which is what where are the
gene projects or did they operate and
finally there's a biological process
branch which just tries the pathways and
the processes the gene products
participate in and so on the right hand
side you can see this is a snapshot from
the Amigo tool at the gene ontology it
has this nested hierarchy following the
is a relationships as denoted with the I
and and you can see so from biological
process branch one of those subtypes is
behavior and you can see next with the
numeric label indicates the number of of
gene products that have been annotated
with that label with that biological
process so as you navigate further down
the tree there will be a narrowing of
the total number of instances that can
be applied but in total there are
800,000 at least reported on the Amigo
website so what's interesting about the
gene ontology is it's it's in essence it
was formulated to handle a problem where
many different biological databases were
crafting their own terms to annotate the
genes and to provide them with a
functional description and so the gene
ontology consortium came together to
establish a common vocabulary that could
be used independently of species and so
on the bottom chart you can see the
distribution of annotations across
different species for instance from
human and mouse and rat and in that
chart it also shows that the
distribution in terms of where those
annotations have experimental evidence
or non experimental evidence so the vast
majority are somewhat included from
computational means but till very human
proteins and mice proteins are very well
studied now
in preparation for this Tosca I also
looked up one of the proteins that I had
worked on very early in my career which
was on rack a1 a GT pas and so in your
product that's one of our protein
databases also includes gene ontology
annotations for protein products and in
our work we looked at through mutational
or perturbations we looked at what rack
1 GT piezas could be doing and we saw
that they apparently control filopodia
information and some utility and then
substances cytokinesis and and
development in slime molds and so these
descriptions these functional
descriptions are captured using gene
ontology terms and as I mentioned so
what for certainly in the case here for
rack 1a it's it's basically a protein
kinase and gtp binding activity and so
if we want to see what are all the
proteins that have gtp binding we can do
that and we can see there's a wide
distribution across all the different
species so this is the big win for an
ontology like the gene ontology is to
see that no matter what kind of
biological organism you are you can use
the same to the terms that are defined
in a consistent manner in your own
biological annotation projects now
clearly the gene ontology on its own is
is a necessary development in the
description of gene products but we also
need a similar terminologies across the
biological scales to describe different
kinds of proteins of different kinds of
organelles of different kinds of cells
and tissues and organs and organisms all
together as we saw with the natural
taxonomy so some disease and phenotypes
ontologies there are key healthcare
terminologies and these are provided
through the umls system where we have
terminologies like sno-med CT for
clinical terminology diseases
diagnostics and procedures the NCI at
the source
is a pretty wide-ranging vocabulary for
clinical care translational basic
research public information
administration activities link for labs
and vital signs and ICD 9 and 10 for
disease epidemiology and bullying on
other efforts have also complemented
these ones in the open biomedical
ontology consortium including the
disease ontology which offers a
standardized ontology for human disease
these are mapped to these u.s.
terminologies and it's complemented with
the human phenotype ontology that
provides phenotypic descriptions for
human hereditary at now many other
diseases and in mailing phenotype
ontology complements the human one by
being a little bit more broad than just
human phenotypes and encompassing and
have been widely used in different kinds
of phenotypic phenotyping experiments
for instance for from my Surat and so on
and only an experimental factor ontology
from European bioinformatics Institute
which takes in all of these different
kinds of ontologies and tries to provide
support for for discovery in in the
context of many different kinds of
experimental data sets so where can you
go and get ontology x' well mark musin
is the PI for the bio portal and
currently contains 517 biomedical
ontologies and over seven seven point
eight million classes so it's obviously
in a new pal and an enormous number of
ontologies it's a great resource for for
biomedical researchers allows you to
search these you analyze ontology x' as
well as the open biomedical ontologies
and many more and there are other
repositories of ontologies and
vocabularies one of these is the length
of the vocabularies effort this is
really largely focused around ontologies
and terminologies to describe data using
semantic web standards for instance the
resource description framework or widely
used outside of that as well
all right so what I'd like to do now is
just give you a quick introduction
against to more of the idea of how do we
how do we formalize or
conceptualizations how do we build
computable ontologies unreason with them
and then follow up with applications so
this again this idea of formalization is
the process by which we mat or
conceptualization so are what are the
kinds of entities that exist in the
domain what are the relationships and
their attributes into some kind of
logical representation and we have we
can kind of see that our logical
representations are essentially a set of
building blocks in which we can combine
them to create machine understandable
expression that have an unambiguous
interpretation and therefore we can
automatically reason about them so again
the idea is that we we have concepts
that we can reuse in different contexts
and and create new expression so for
instance this wrong description logics
is one of these languages that can use
to the law ologies and we can define
something for instance like a
transcription factor as being a kind of
protein that binds to DNA molecules and
regulates the rate of transcription so
this is an expression that we can
describe in description logics and
therefore then we can ask questions
about things that bind to DNA or things
that regulate the rate of transcription
and we would discover that transcription
factors satisfy these so one of the
languages that we have available to
build ontology is the owl which is
stands for the web ontology language it
is a product of the World Wide Web
Consortium and has gone through a couple
of different iterations now and is the
de facto standard for building
computable ontologies on the Semantic
Web there are many other languages that
are available of course with all kinds
of interesting properties
and which which may be better suited for
particular projects but this is the one
that I'll focus on here so one of the
challenges of again this formalization
process is now you don't really have to
think about what you are saying to a
machine that now it matters how how you
describe something because the
interpretation may may be ammonius to us
if we don't correctly capture it in the
first place so how specifies a
vocabulary and grammar to express more
precisely what we mean when we are
describing entities of interest it
provides us with the ability to
articulate different kinds of things or
classes the relations or properties and
to describe even data so individuals and
their specific values so different kinds
of aspects of the language briefly on
disjointness where we want to know
whether things are the same or different
from one another we can quantify our
relationships so we can say for instance
that if we wanted to define the class of
parents we would expect that a parent
would have at least one child and so we
have this range that we can quantify
over some relationship we have a
vocabulary for negation where we can say
something is it's not the case so for
instance that we can say that penguins
are kinds of birds but they do not fly
for instance we also have aspects that
relate to disjunction so basically the
ability to express a union and a variety
of different property characteristics
for automated reasoning so for instance
for transitivity for inferring
functional properties or inverse
functional properties and symmetric
properties and so on
and there's a few other aspects that are
like complex class expressions property
chains that are very useful but are
probably more more seldom reused so what
do we get with reasoning over how
ontology is well there's a number of
different properties
of numbered if you have aspects that we
can use the first is consistency where
we can determine whether an ontology
contains contradictions
there's satisfiability where we can
determine whether classes can have
instances or whether they're logically
basically unsatisfiable that no
instances could ever fulfill the
description that's provided because it's
logically inconsistent we can compute
some sumption where we're asking our
instances of one class also instances of
another cost they satisfy those those
minimal requirements we can perform
classification where we repeatedly apply
subsumption to discover links between
name classes and finally we can perform
realization where we if we have
individuals in our knowledge base we can
see if they are members of classes that
are defined in the ontology
so we can use tools like Protege which
is also developed by mark to construct
how long Tala geez its it implements the
owl standard and it's extensible people
have been writing plugins so there's a
wonderful software framework to build on
and exploit tautologies that are being
built I show a screen shot in the lower
hand side where again I did I designed a
quick and dirty ontology just to
describe that proteins are how amino
acids as their part and there are also
types of molecules so this you know can
be done very quickly very readily there
are also other products on on the market
to build ontology is including for
instance top rate composer which offers
this graphical interface but they both
share this very common view where you
have this tree like view different
classes and a description of their of
their properties the attributes right so
just a quick focus here on the protégé
editor and you can see this is the
layout so
we have on the upper left-hand side the
class hierarchy organic molecule and we
have proteins that are types subclasses
of organic molecules and amino acids
that are also subclasses of organic
molecules and in the lower left panel
you can see a property that we have
defined which is the house part and so
this now we have our terminology in our
domain which is the different kinds of
objects that were interested in organic
molecules proteins amino acids and a
relation to help relate these to any of
the two entity two or more entities of
interest which is has part so in the
right hand lower right hand side you can
craft these logical expressions to
describe the relationships that exist
between these entities so for instance
now we're focused on the protein entity
we have to subclass axioms the first is
that so we have that every protein is a
kind of organic molecule and stuff forms
the genus of our definition and then
secondly that that proteins are
comprised or have amino acids as part so
that's our differential and so the pro
noce editor offers this autocomplete
service that helps you craft these owl
syntactic to syntactically correct
owl expressions um so this this is just
you know again this is easy enough for
everybody to do to go to the Protege
website to download the tool to start
playing around with ontologies and
reasoner's one of the ontology is that
we have built is the semantic science
integrated ontology or silo and it it
captures many of the different basic
kinds of things in the domain and
divides up the world into three aspects
objects and processes and their
attributes and then we can create even
more sophisticated expressions for each
of the basic biomedical data types of
interest so here I show you the
hierarchy that relates to - that goes
all the way down to a protein and there
are other ontology is out there
that provide descriptions of proteins
and other kinds of biomolecules but
suffice to say that because we have also
added these axioms into the ontology we
can ask questions that are not just
about to retrieve the label like used
labels of things to retrieve this the
types of things of interest but we can
actually use the ax and we can ask
whether or not for instance where all
the things that have amino acid residues
as a part and we get protein of course
as one of our answers polypeptides
enzymes antibodies protein complexes and
amino acid residues are themselves by by
definition are are wholly themselves so
you also see another term there which is
all nothing and the protege a pedicure
by default shows you that that the
subclass of all things is nothing so
it's just an artifact of the of the of
the language ok so in the last bit what
I hope to do is talk to you about some a
couple different applications in
biomedicine
to give you a sense of what what we and
others are doing in this domain and by
no means is this comprehensive there's a
vast body of work and hopefully you'll
see more of it in the seminar series but
here's here's a few different
applications that that I want to bring
to your attention so sno-med CT is one
of these ontology s that are used in the
healthcare domain it's used across many
different countries and by many
providers in the United States it
provides common vocabulary for recording
clinical data and it's comprised of
about three hundred twenty four thousand
classes so it's a huge ontology and on
the right hand side you can see it's
spread that sort of snapshot of a part
of sno-med CT towards the upper level so
their body structures clinical findings
organisms pharmaceuticals procedures and
so on lots of different things in there
now so mat CT uses a pattern based
knowledge counter so they really want to
again the features of each of the
categories that you see there but you
can see the expression is very difficult
to parse you have to pretty much be
trained in this that the idea is that
once you adopt a kind of pattern for
defining your your genus or group
diferencia then you can actually
automatically construct and validate the
ontology so we'll show you an example
here where the kaiser permanente had
done some work to extend snowmen to
express some different kinds of
categories in particular non viral
pneumonia in which again here this term
contains an element of negation you're
looking for things that are not viral
and infectious no Morea which would be
caused by a virus or bacterium so here
you have a disjunctive clause double
pneumonia which occurs in two ones or
using this cardinality description in an
implementation of this called snowman
owl you can express these kinds of
definitions and when you use an
automated reasoner what's interesting is
that it failed to find some of the
expected subsumption for instance a
bacterial pneumonia is a kind of non
viral pneumonia and part of the reason
is that the ontology was under
constrained it didn't know the ontology
we didn't provide the reason or
information that said that virus and
bacteria are not the same things which
are required to make the entailment but
adding disjointness in this concept led
to other results from the reasoner and
for instance that one of the classes
that became inconsistent is this taneous
embolization I have patek artery using
fluoroscopy guidance and the cause of
this inconsistency which you can learn
by asking the reasoner to provide you
with some justification for the
inconsistency is that there was a
problem in the description of going of
groin which was asserted to be a
subclass of both an abdomen and leg and
these were these are disjoint and
ontology and so
this results in the total like a huge
amount of inconsistency in the ontology
so the nice thing about using a language
like all a formal language along with
the reasoner is that when you again when
you're making these kinds of statements
when you're providing the descriptions
that at least provide necessary
conditions if not sufficient conditions
it can find those those expressions that
are contradictory to one another another
increasingly I mean just like we saw
with the gene ontology where we're using
an ontology for annotation of genes we
also use for instance phenotype ontology
to do deep clinical phenotype in up
patients so here this is one tool called
phenotypes which uses the human
phenotype ontology to provide
descriptions of human patients and so it
provides you the ability to navigate to
basically a easier navigation of the
ontology itself but the ability to sort
of say that the inference is a patient
has or does not have specific signs or
symptoms of some disorder and provides a
sort of a computable representation of
this this description this kind of
information this deep clinical
phenotyping used in autologous can be
used to match patients together so fiown
central is one of these tool are portals
that can be used to find patients that
match the one that that you're looking
at or that you've characterized so
you'll have a set of phenotypes for your
patient and through measures of semantic
similarity you're going to try to find
patients that are most like this one and
in this tool because it's focused on
rare diseases the idea is to find other
patients that share similar phenotypes
and potentially share the same disease
etiology and so there's the opportunity
to communicate with other providers that
that know something about these patients
another application here using
phenotypic ontologies or disease
ontologies is to pinpoint more
accurately
the genetic basis for disorders so in
this work here for FedEx where once you
collect genomic information about a
patient coupled with this deep clinical
phenotyping and modeling it or looking
at the different disorders that have
been described in for instance the
orphanet or MMR clinvar it becomes
possible to prioritize the set of genes
that come up from some variant analysis
coupled with the phenotypic profile to
identify the genes that are most likely
to be responsible for eliciting the
phenotypes that we observe so this has
been applied and has helped to identify
individuals with fairly rare disorders
that occur very infrequently but the
fact that we have these descriptions
allow us to I don't identify candidate
genes
all right so finally what I want to do
is just tell you about another some of
the work that we have been doing where
we use quantities for drug discovery so
one of the projects that we did was to
identify human drug targets using the
phenotypes from knockout mice models and
the basically that the effects of the
the side-effects of known drugs and so
the main idea here is that if we can
compare the phenotypes of night knockout
mouse models with the effects of drugs
that when they are similar it would
suggest that the drug might be an
inhibitor of that gene which which
produces that phenotypic profile so to
do this kind of experiment though the
problem is that drugs are and their
effects are expressed using a Metra
or ulis terminology this is from one of
the Davis is called cider which
basically does text mining using
ontology
over product structure public labels and
we also have phenotypes from the from
the most genome database which are
expressed using the mammalian phenotype
ontology so we basically have
now the problem that we have like apples
and oranges on the one hand we have the
million phenotypes and then on the other
hand we have drug effects but they're
not using the same vocabulary so it's
hard to do the comparison between for
instance a drug side effect profile and
and a mouse model phenotypic profile so
what we have to do at that point is
create mappings or correspondence
between the different terminologies and
this is really what mappings are used
for to to establish a correspondence
between one one term and another term
from different vocabularies and so this
allows us to have a common when we can
map one set of terms to another it
allows us then to compare apples with
apples again and so we use measures of
what we call semantic similarity to
compare a list of for instance drug
effects with a list of mice model
phenotypes and then we can looking at
their the intersection over their Union
we can assign a score that says just how
similar those those profiles are to one
another so when we do that when we
compute the similarity between drug and
birth drugs and their effects and mice
models and their fan types what we find
is that we can in fact recover drug
targets in this way pretty accurately in
a way that's fairly surprising that
phenotypic information information about
the effects of of knocking out genes and
mice often look like the effects that we
see in in drugs as well that target
those genes so when we do our comparison
against drug Bank which is a database of
known drug targets get ROC AZ 0.72 and
when we look for human targets in
another Daly Scott stitch which is both
manually curated and automatically
derived drug targets we do slightly
better and we do the best for when we're
trying to identify most mice targets but
our success varies depending on the
receptor type or the target type
so one of the interesting findings is
that we can by doing this we can also
pinpoint multiple physiological targets
of these drugs so for instance for
diclofenac which is in non-steroidal
agent is used to treat pain
osteoarthritis and rheumatoid arthritis
what we find is that 46 percent of the
effects of the drug can be explained by
a Cox to knock code which has features
like inflammation gastritis constipation
upper GI tract pain and the other
roughly 50% can be explained by knock of
a 2 PP Arg
and this regulates metabolism
proliferation information and
differentiation so so these genes when
they're knocked out they give you a you
know and this is the whole basis for a
lot of biology which is this
perturbation to uncover gene function
they tell you what roles that the
participating in and we can sort of see
that in terms of when the drugs are also
inhibiting those genes okay so in
summary I know that this was a kind of a
quick a quick run through ontology
obviously there there's much much more
to ontology but I think here the hope is
to describe to you in a way that
hopefully you get some sense of the
different tensions that we have in
building ontology z' by considering the
many contributions of the field of
philosophy of metaphysics to
understanding the world and the kinds of
things that exist and how what
relationships hold between them
there are many formal theories of
otology then we try to implement in
practice using you know formal languages
like owl and others and primarily you
know all again is one of our de-facto
languages it's extremely powerful but
it's also very easy to to get on and so
when you're building ontology nothing
the only way that you can find that you
made an error is that if your ontology
are sufficiently expressive you've made
temp to again formalize these
differential between the different
classes and then the reason we'll do a
lot of hard work for you to try to find
inconsistencies and not in those
descriptions what I hope I've convinced
you is that ontology is have a wide
variety of biomedical uses from basic
answering of questions
this is one of you know big motivations
from you know once again a shared
understanding of these different terms
that if you ask questions you get
answers for them and the way that you
expected them but then also that they
have a role to play in data integration
and in a variety of biomedical knowledge
discovery settings ok so I want to
acknowledge a number of individuals
I have shamelessly stolen and adapted
slides from leaders in the field
including Marc Newson who was here at
Stanford barry smith who's at the
interstate buffalo preeminent
philosopher in the field of medical
oncology in particular ian horrocks who
one of the architects for the web
ontology language robert under fabric of
mind where we do this drug discovery
work using autologous listen handle who
is working on integration of Genentech
fanta descriptions across species and
her monarch initiative and Paul Scofield
but it's also been contributing to that
and many other things all right and with
that like to thank you for your
attention I'm happy to take any
questions thanks Michel that was
fantastic
again everyone who has questions should
cite their questions into the chat with
this many people on the call it was
unmute everyone the new background those
would be terrible so please put your
questions in the chat box and we'll try
to get them in order while people are
typing really early ask you a question
she'll one of the tensions that feel on
the Big Data community is a question
about whether ontology czar even worth
it that that means the this is is
undercurrent that you know oncology's
are large the hearts build hard to
maintain
can't we just learn all the distinctions
that we need in data and is it possible
that the advent of the Big Data
revolution will make ontology less
important here's what you might have
about that yeah that's a really good
question mark um there have been there
are increasing numbers of attempts to
build data-driven ontology x' Trey
Ideker published a paper I think a
couple years ago now I think it was
called Nexo where she was trying to
learn the cellular compartments or
basically the part of the gene ontology
dealing with the cellular components
from interaction data so in some sense
you know some of the relationships that
we see in ontology is the way the things
that we know and the relations are hope
to them should be evidence in the data
that we are collecting the problem is of
course that what we what we often use
ontology for is this communication
between individuals about the terms that
they use and what they mean and and you
know frankly science is constantly
changing right our understanding of the
basic kinds of things and what they do
is always changing annotations about
proteins versus functional descriptions
of proteins are being added and also
retracted and they need to be evidenced
by experiments and it seems to me that
you know the value of of having you know
again a consistent set of terms to use
for annotation which fundamentally
enables the kinds of computations that
we do are I don't think that people who
only for instance use a text line
compound nouns or anything like that
would be able to find the same kinds of
things that we did when we have these
structured annotations text mining
itself is hugely enhanced by having you
know terminologies to use and that
includes you know capturing all the
different kinds of synonyms and in
various languages so it seems like we
will always need at least for the
foreseeable future an involvement of
humans to ensure the accuracy of the
kinds
things that were interested in and
particularly to provide this query
answering capability of course I'm shown
to be you know like also that even that
is being challenged by systems like
Watson that are capable of learning and
associations between different terms and
to answer simple questions or questions
like on the Jeopardy challenge that we
saw so but but even Watson uses
structured terminologies so it seems
like you know it's some combination
thereof and I think those are going to
be you know the most successful projects
are going to think a little bit about
how far can we go with data and then do
we need some extra input from humans
because the data just isn't sufficient
to do the task that we're looking for
you raise an interesting issue Michele
and that is that science changes as
suddenly you learn that you can have
reverse transcriptase and you can make
DNA from RNA or sometimes you really
find out that Pluto is no longer a
planet not given the fact that the world
changes how do you know whether your
ontology czar actually still valid
mention that sno-med is more than
300-thousand terms how do you know where
the bugs are yeah that's that's I think
where you know ontology needs some
software engineering right I think we
see where increasingly seen and we use
this in our own ontology development
these patterns where we can instantiate
class descriptions in some regular way
and by doing that we know that we can
check the consistency of the knowledge
that we're offering and I think that
scales to really big ontology is it used
to be you know 10 10 years ago
enormous ly challenging to reason about
a very large ontology likes nomads and
today you can do it in you know
extremely short periods of time it's
entirely feasible to do the problem I
think the bigger problem is the fact
that we have 500 ontology x' right
there's so many to choose from they are
partially overlapping they're also
possibly incomplete with the domain
because of the changes right or on or
under
ending and so if you start you know
using one ontology and another one comes
in that is you know potentially you know
applicable for you how you how do you
make sense that how do you use multiple
ontology and not you know confuse
everybody about what it is that you're
doing or how to use this in some
computational ways so I think this is
one of the next great challenges is
making sense of the 500-plus ontology is
in bio portal in a way that users that
are trying to do their tasks which let's
say sanitation or analysis are pretty
much like they don't need to worry about
all this other stuff but getting to that
point I think is still poses a
significant challenge for all of us I
agree a questioner is asking how to
developers of ontologies get feedback
from the communities that use them and I
try to other any kinds of standards or
tools that can facilitate that kind of
feedback
my understanding is Sochi if you go to
bio portal for instance is that you'll
see you know metadata about the ontology
which includes often includes the home
page for the ontology but more and more
on these ontology based efforts have
some kind of mailing list or discussion
forum as well as issue trackers this is
some of these things are for instance
foundational principles and they open
biomedical ontology community people can
make suggestions for new terms they
could suggest revisions and so on
however again there's no guarantee that
your terms that you're suggesting
they're going to be incorporated people
have vigorous debates about the
definition of things and this certainly
happens in the healthcare terminology
setting whether it's ICD or snowmen or
whatnot
this pits people against each other
trying to figure out what what what
exactly are we talking about here and
which if we do this is it pragmatic for
for the users of these autologous so
that tension is always there but I think
the biggest thing and something that
encourage everybody is that you
when you see something not quite working
the way that you had hoped that I think
at this point we're sort of beyond the
Bonanza the Wild West of ontology
building with so many now now it's
really going to be about refinement and
hopefully some consolidation right some
some ability for us to have a coherent
view of all of these ontologies that is
maximally useful for for all users the
question points out that there's another
ontology language called oboe and
wonders how that's different from owl
and why are them why they would fly
through more than one language for
building autologous yeah so although
some oboe one of the one of the early
benefits of oboe is a very simple
language again to capture these basic
definitions of you know so human
readable labels definition synonyms and
had been extended to contain again the
ability to do this hierarchical
organization and descriptions the kinds
of relationships and some work I think
maybe seven or seven years ago or
something was to then map languages like
oboe to the web ontology language so
there is a formal now semantics to oboe
it mirrors what we see an owl and so
oboe is like now syntax that can express
the oval a big owl axioms that you might
generate and vice versa um the you know
again from the perspective of language
development or many languages of course
I only touched on one there are many
more expressive languages than the owl
there are lots of reasons to choose a
different kind of language but but
frankly this is this is a this is a
standard from the w3c and just like how
HTML you know provided a generic
platform for us to to read webpages with
a single browser we can we can browse
the whole internet use it for very large
part of the internet using that what we
don't want to see is is you know
languages that don't
interoperate with one another so well
what I get the sense of is that new
languages or new developments are
building on the sympathies formally
defined semantics providing a
correspondence between different
languages and then in that way we extend
the cat our capacity to express
different kinds of constructs yeah is
there a standard ontology database
endorsed by NIH that allows conversion
between disparate resources and would
buy a portal potentially be it yeah I
don't know mark is it I don't think
early goes over on endorsing standards
but I think my portal probably would be
hidden as much as it is the resource
that contains all the publicly available
oncology's and biomedicine risk other
resources tend to be more selective so
in some sense I think my quota might be
that that resource but I think it's it's
really up to a user's need and what
their applications require yeah I mean
there are other ontology report
repositories there the European
bioinformatics Institute have have an
ontology repository there is this on to
the ontology repository they have our
ontology repository and then there's a
variety of ontology report repositories
that go beyond the biomedical scope like
the tones one and so on so there's a
smattering of different ontology
repositories
many of them are drawing from the source
code like repositories where these
ontologies are stored they offer some
kind of both archival and or you know
change view functionality so I think
it's it's just a matter of you know look
looking at them and seeing what works
for you okay are many people are
conversing or skilled in using multiple
oncology's oh I'm not sure if that's a
question about the workforce or a
training question or or was necessary to
actually conduct work in work in this
area is there much more to be done in
the mapping between ontology
maybe does your two questions mmm okay
so the first question pertains to so is
it is it common for us to use multiple
intelligences serve mark is that right
yeah yeah okay so and I guess are there
many people who can do it
Oh are there many people who can do it
um like any place what is the job market
for oncologist look well clearly uh you
know again like the gene ontology and I
think you know has has provided or
afforded so much tool development
software development many bioinformatics
researchers are fundamentally you know
familiar with that we can use the gene
ontology for enrichment analysis all
kinds of Association analysis all kinds
of functions there so there's plenty of
tutorials and code and and training
material as to using an ontology like
the the gene ontology for biological
data analysis and similarly I'd argue
that probably in the healthcare domain
there's you know the similar kinds of
things that are be done for a cohort
analysis risk analysis or colleague Nick
and Shawn does this kind of work on
using ontologies for processing the
notes of electronic healthcare records
and subsequently doing analyses to to
look at cohorts and and there was you
know diseases and so on um you know I
think it's it's mostly a matter of these
use cases in our work where we look at
multiple properties of for instance
drugs stemming from the molecular to
epidemiological we're dealing with trip
of all kinds of terminologies
well you upwards twenty different
terminologies for one analysis coupled
with you know ten to fifteen different
databases and so on so it becomes a
pretty big project but increasingly
easier to do we offer for instance
another project that we do is called by
RDF where we have data in a uniform kind
of representation using semantic web
standards you couple that with the on
apologies you vastly reduce the amount
of work that you have to do
you to to use those data but it's up to
you to think about the application that
you you want to pursue great what what
tools are available to identify ontology
terms in literature yeah well um so I
mean I can't out here so the ncpo which
mark leads has an annotator tool so you
can pick and choose the ontology z' you
want to use to do an annotation task so
that's very useful I know there's a UI
an API component that's that's a real
quick and dirty kind of way to start
analyzing text that match the terms that
you have in the ontology space again the
challenges is really worrying about
potential false positives a lot of terms
especially acronyms have multiple
different kinds of meanings are not
unambiguous they mapped many different
things so I think the challenge with
certainly text mining with ontologies is
you have to really think about your use
case if you're interested in a
large-scale analysis where you don't
you're not asking a question about any
individual then you should be able to
find signal over noise even if you don't
do a great job of always being precise
with your annotations now that that
doesn't always hold true for some kinds
of diseases or procedures that you're
looking at it's you're using very common
words and then and then it's just
practically impossible without some some
other corresponding information there
are other toolkits increasingly we see
also aspects to do some kind of deep
learning over text over text to better
extra or either identify entities or
extract relations lots of work is being
done there but again it's working with
text is extremely challenging and I
think that there's there's plenty of
work left to be done to improve the
methods for for good use of ontology
over text
what do you do in the situation when the
ontology has categorized an entity and
it doesn't fit cleanly of questioner ask
what do you do with aspirin within one
content it's a pain reliever in another
context it's blood thinner oh how do you
answer your simple questions like what
is this entity unclassified you know
that's a really good question it's
actually one that works struggling with
right now as we look as we use you know
we try to do prediction of nutri
indications and a lot of these
indications are drawn from actually text
mind annotations in which there are many
you know incorrect values um we you know
I it's a it's a very difficult problem I
think our approach is mostly that you
can create optimal structures or
knowledge structures that capture or for
instance the context in which some
function or functionality is being
executed so again if you want to
articulate that the aspirin can act as a
you know potential blood thinner in some
circumstance then you you really need
the ontology or the description to do
that we have developed a tool called
high q-- where we have this event based
representation where we sort of say okay
what are the components in the event
what are the agents that that for
instance potentially cause change and
what's the biological context or what's
the circumstances in which this can this
occurs and so this this kind of
approaches event based representation is
also very prominent and other kinds of
of analyses analytical analyses but is
not really prevalent in the way we
currently construct ontology
there's this modulation of the context
whether in space or time or other you
know interactions with other systems is
not is not often done but increasingly I
think you know work that the monarch
Chris Mangal Melissa Handel Peter
Robinson and others are doing also
striving to capture this sort of
information so it's a little bit of
provenance a little bit of context and I
think an enhancement of the description
of the
functional circumstances that need to
happen so we do it in our work but it's
not prevalent I think in doing this even
when you look at uniprot that captures
these you know again these annotations
of like like I showed you four rack rack
1a functions this kind of like control
only really you know may happen under
some circumstances and not others and
that's not necessarily detailed what
they'll what they'll tell you is what's
the experimental evidence for the
annotation that you see but not
necessarily before context that you need
to unambiguously interpret or understand
and what context that's occurring thanks
Michel we have reached the end of the
hour the questions that fantastic we
actually have many more questions that
would be get to better fortunately we
talked at the time let me thank you for
your presentations what which was
wonderful I only thank everybody who
dialed in and everybody who will watch
the replay of your talk online and we'll
have another run session next week
thanks everyone okay bye